let's just get it out the way what we
paid for the fight
yes yeah unfortunately we did but no
that's not to say
you know i mean i would never illegally
stream anything i don't think you would
either
no absolutely not i mean i wouldn't
download a car well
wouldn't download a gun wouldn't
download a gun by any by any means so
yeah no i would never no i did try that
uh
that's the pirated stream link though
just wasn't really working
just to make sure no one else was
exactly to make sure it wasn't working i
wanted to give it more traffic
yeah so that it would would crunch
should crash yeah yeah
same same i was like everyone come on
watch the pirated link we have to crash
it yeah everyone's sending it to
everyone i knew yeah yeah yeah i was
text i was texting people and like open
it on four computers we just
we have to crash the stream yeah yeah so
you know
which i think you know we're doing a
good job because
it stopped working exactly every 10
seconds exactly so then
me and all my friends were to buy the
fight which was the intention yeah
of that plan that's the only point in
time when i felt safe buying the fight
knowing that the stream was dying yeah
to go
yeah it's time to buy time to buy yeah
so
and i bought it on like every single one
of my devices
separately same which is cool
shout out to face jarvis did his thing
i'm happy for the guy gone
meme
i'm happy for the guy he went from
getting banned from fortnite and
crying on stream to knocking somebody
the [ __ ] out
that was the best clip of the whole
fight he had the coldest knockout the
whole night yeah
yeah that kid's a killer wow go ahead
i was just gonna ask what's the deal
with ryan johnston did that fight come
before
yeah it was before okay so first of all
first of all
to this little you know mud mouth
[ __ ] who doesn't recognize my
fight iq analysis that's not even a real
sentence but just put that together who
are you talking about numb nuts
you know i have a great reverence for
ryan johnston
okay someone had the gall to discredit
my
absolute fanaticism for ryan johnson
he goes i think cody predicted this guy
winning
you're wrong you're wrong
i've been watching ryan johnson since he
was
26 and a half what is he now almost 27.
i'm watching him for about two months
ever since two months ago i've been
watching ryan johnson and i knew he was
going to do work
this weekend also that comment is way
off base in
more ways more ways than just that to to
think that
you weren't the one that predicted
something in the fighting fighting
related
related thing and to think that i would
ever predict anything
correctly
[Laughter]
is so beyond stupid yeah i think that's
what pissed me off it's like you don't
even listen to this podcast you clearly
don't
listen to this podcast at all have you
ever seen the blank stare in cody's eyes
when i talk about mma
you [ __ ] idiot you can hear it yeah
see
nothing yes this weekend great
absolutely great
series of fights i mean that's right
what's up
so here ryan johnston he he took
w kale can i see the clip of that one
i think he gassed out i can't remember
can we play a clip of that or will we
get
dunked donk we get bonked on
um man
you know we won't go into too much but
you know
i've like talked in the past about like
the it you know like the killer instinct
and just fighters recognizing that yeah
out of all of them that night face
jarvis had it yeah
that kid dude if you go back and watch
his walkout from like the moment that
smoke clears like you just
see it like he's primal that's the
com that's the polar opposite of the
look in my eyes when you talk about
fighting yeah
yeah yeah polar opposite
[Music]
i felt so bad for that kid michael lee
because he was going out and
um you ever notice how when fighters go
out to fight they just look
slightly sweaty sorry all right slightly
what
sweaty yeah yeah why is listening a
little bit why is that i was wondering
that
it's because their coaches spray them
down water give them a little kiss on
the cheek
go out there kill them no that's all
shiny typically they're warming up a
little bit like they're hitting pads
lightly like they're they're trying to
get
trying to get turned on yeah i'm trying
to get the fighter chub
got it so michael lee came out
dries
drier than like middle-aged underwear
just
a middle-aged woman's underwear just
[ __ ] clean
and he's walking and you can see like he
has no idea what he's doing he's like
trying to
like get his brain to think like i'm
gonna be in a fight now
and he starts pounding his fist to like
get warmed up and i just started shaking
my head i'm like
no one does that and he's like
he's like throwing like his hands to the
camera he's like whoa let's go
face jarvis gets out there like
borderline twitching on the jaw just
like
i'm gonna kill this kid i'm gonna kill
him
and that's what he did he killed that
dude
so hats off to face jarvis man that
knockout was
nasty yeah shout out to face jarvis by
the way guys yeah just
let me ask you this who is michael lee
isn't some tick tocker
i have no id what does he do like what
is his normal stick maybe he
like dances or something like 46 million
followers or something crazy
it's i think i don't know that was the
worst part of that whole fight
every time they bring a person on stage
he's got six million subscribers on
youtube
[Music]
like [ __ ] jesus christ i mean there
was so
there was a lot of comedy i have to give
i have to give it this
at least everyone who went in there
tried
yeah you know what i mean like all of
them tried to train to some degree they
they actually
took it seriously in some capacity yeah
you know so i think in that way
all the logan money should have gone to
them yeah because they think they gave a
[ __ ] yeah they tried to get hit
yeah and so um
i mean a lot of those fights they were
so lopsided yeah it was like oh
all of them was like very clearly one
guy was better oh yeah yeah
yeah i know it's funny because you know
why i actually kind of like the
celebrity boxing [ __ ] or whatever like
this whole
thing going on right now where it's like
like that wasn't the only fight that was
aaron carter and
lamar odom lamar odom fought for
barstool or whatever
yeah earlier that day right it was the
night before the night before it's like
and it's gonna keep happening yeah but i
kind of like it because
because it's like if you get knocked out
like bryce hall did you're you're the
laughing stock of the internet for
for a long time i mean like it's going
to be a while yeah and so it's like you
have to take it seriously you kind of
have to but yeah if you get knocked out
it's humiliating yeah
yeah well dude all the [ __ ]
i mean i feel for the guy man yeah can
we just play can we just play this one
jesus christ and here's the thing man
i'm not i don't want to get on like some
kind of high horse but i
have to present this question okay do
you think
he'd be as humble if he won what do you
mean
you know how like afterward he's like
i'm not a fighter man you know it's all
right he's joking around do you think he
would have had that attitude if he won
he'd be like i told you i'm a [ __ ]
fighter that's where i struggled to
really
have empathy for him oh yeah i'm like
you you acted like a dick leading up and
then now you want to like
get a pat on the back for being like a
nice guy yeah [ __ ] that man
what was that i think someone on the
ship just sneezed
this is the funniest [ __ ] ever i'm not a
boxer i'm not a fighter i've never
claimed to be a fighter
i'm gonna knock out austin because i'm
an actual fighter and i got two guns
right here
i am a fighter i have a wrestling
background
he said it twice in that same intro
he said it twice dude it's so
funny i've never claimed to be a fighter
i'm gonna knock him out because i am a
fighter yeah
here's a here's the jar phase jarvis
knockout
i see michael lee what they have to tell
these kids going in tie your hair up or
cut it yeah do you know how much worse
the knockout looks when you have this
like this main look at this when it's
bumped see ya
it looked like a toupee got punched off
his head
the bryce hall one did you oh bro oh
yeah his toupee definitely came back
yeah man man oh man
i'm surprised no one has memed the clip
of him in his interview before his fight
they're like what do you think you're
going to do tonight bryce he's like i'm
definitely getting a ko
what kl's are going today i'm definitely
getting one
you got one brother you definitely got
one man
and here's the thing i don't i don't buy
this whole you know
oh at least they had the courage to get
in the ring you guys are getting like
millions of dollars
yeah there's there's no like courage to
get in the ring for five actually
no the courage is this is what i'm
saying yeah yeah this is the
this is the risk you're right you're
right yeah right i'm not saying like he
didn't train he
all i'm saying is like i'm glad they
took it seriously because yeah
and and people will keep taking it
seriously because of this yeah it's like
the more this becomes more popular the
more it gets memed the more people watch
yeah and like you you know if you sign
up for this [ __ ] you it's not like
you got to go hard you know the other
thing i just
you know the taylor holder just needs to
come clean about it
which you lost they i guess they
overturned it
and they made it a win for gibb yeah i
think so i mean
the the funniest thing was like i think
on his uh
his instagram story he was like
i don't agree with the decision but you
know the nerves got to me i'm like just
say it bro
just say it you lost you didn't do
anything
yeah there it is boys we officially got
the w yeah
thanks for the support yeah as it should
have been man
it's kind of shitty that he didn't get
to like celebrate that on stage though
yeah
so whack yeah so whack man i like how
you called it
a stage or i would because that's what
it is
yeah it is a stage that's true yeah it
is a stage that's true
[Laughter]
dude it's so it's so funny because
okay i think the greatest thing here is
er like oh god
just a lot of the funniest [ __ ] imagine
if the headline performance after the
last fight was jack harlow
and they put addison on stage and she's
dancing with jack
and now you're headlining talent jack
[Applause]
harlow
oh god that that's like a
that's a comedy film waiting to happen
dude
oh my god and he does like the
you know the equivalent of stacy's mom
yeah
jesus man it's up there addison grinding
off
don't perform my new song i took your
business twice i never claimed to be a
fighter either
[Laughter]
but i am a lover though
oh my god addison's like yes he is
that's bad jesus christ man i think
there was something
kind of you know a little bit poetic
about that whole card though
to see like a silver lining you're
looking at me like what could this
possibly be
what is it poetic thing of no man i
think
it was a it's like a great example of
some [ __ ] takes time and you
success is like determined almost like
by attrition like
gibb has fought before he took a
horrible loss and he had to live with
that for a long time
and he got in shape yeah and he got and
he got and he came to this
and you know taylor's like i'm training
with canelo man i'm this and that and
gives looking nice like i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah you've never been in there you
don't know what it's like and you don't
know what i'm gonna [ __ ] do to you
it's like and what happened taylor got
there he had all that flashy training
all those youtube videos
he he sparred with canelo and he froze
up and it's like
i feel like i didn't get i did i didn't
really feel that depressed
afterwards you know like the production
was really [ __ ] good really actually
take a note man and there's a lot of
like funny [ __ ] that happened
yeah so i didn't really feel like i got
robbed no if you're if you're talking
about like the money you spent
that was a streaming ticket honestly it
was well worth it
i don't think they're gonna make their
money back though no i don't think
there's any way they did
no i was watching a interview with uh
austin mcbroom beforehand which i mean
that's
a [ __ ] dark place you know watching
an interview with
like just like what am i doing like were
you sitting with the lights off
yeah that's all he was like
he was like it was the bff's podcast and
and
uh dave porton i was like so how many
things how many pay-per-view buys do you
think you're gonna get and he was like
i'm thinking about 1.7 million it's like
just just no way
no [ __ ] way wouldn't that wouldn't
that be like the top 15 of pay-per-view
buys ever
yeah it's something like that yes i mean
they think they're the like
they think that they're like the most
influential people ever
no it's like no one real i don't know
like no
no like look at the look at your youtube
analytics
yeah i guarantee you it's like 14 year
old girls that watch your videos
yeah they're not buying a fight
pay-per-view
i mean you saw that stadium that's it
was
empty yeah i kind of chuckled it
uh i i like i look i was like looking at
different like post fight stuff
and you know everyone who lost
throughout some number of how many
people were there it was different for
everyone
i was crazy to perform in 20 in front of
20 000 people or 15 000 people which i'm
sure that was in there i'm like yeah but
that was like
a 100k cap venue yeah yeah
dj khaled felt that [ __ ] oh my god did
we have that clip
he felt that
[Music]
[Music]
what did he start saying after that
it's just like also he still had the
song in his monitor maybe
probably yeah yeah so he's just singing
along and he thinks
it is so hype in there it's that's so
sad i feel bad for the guy holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow that's what i mean that's what i
mean you see stuff like this and you
don't get you're not getting robbed you
know that's worth 50 bucks
that's definitely worth 50 bucks right
there i was thinking man
uh that was a probably pretty good show
like for 50 bucks like you got migos
khalid yeah yeah a little baby yeah
for 50 bucks yeah actually yeah well
baby's performance was actually good
yeah and there's no
difficulty getting to the front he's all
teenagers he's just pushing this
excuse me
me i know your parents i'm going to tell
them that you're here if you don't move
to the side
i'm sorry front row man yeah that's true
so i mean amigos have
really been on a tear every boxing event
bro they got it
it's crazy i bet dude i bet they get a
sick paycheck for that
probably fat
and we have to do one yeah just one song
what do you think it is 200k probably
for each no
for the whole group for once it's one
song it's probably like six million each
probably costs more than the whole fight
honestly
i don't know yeah i mean whatever it is
it's good it's easy money for them
wow so i'm happy for them you know i'm
happy for the performers
yeah i'm happy everyone got paid you
know social gloves
you deserve getting kicked in the nuts
financially for that robbery you pulled
up also brutal name
social gloves yep change it change the
name
yeah cause that's a bad name i think
they would have needed almost like 340
000 pay-per-view buys just to cover like
probably what they spent on talent in
production like just to break even that
would be my assumption they probably got
that
you think i think so all right
i mean who knows we should just say they
didn't yeah we just make it up yeah yeah
i can't believe social gloves made zero
dollars i just went bankrupt everyone
there was
was paid to be there yeah there were
free tickets given away so
and then the pay-per-view was entirely
cracked yeah that's why we were
working with our friends to buy more
tickets because we were trying to
support you know smaller creators yeah
yeah
yeah i mean it's on us i feel like
smaller
to help smaller creators we needed to
help awesome mcbroom yeah get some more
yeah get some more private jet flights